werte kollegen frau bundeskanzlerin sie
haben über die unsicherheit gesprochen
die der brh exit bringen wird nicht dass
wir dabei viel neues erfahren hätten es
war nämlich ihre erprobte mischungen aus
phrasen und baldrian und eines ist klar
dieser exit wie teuer teuer für die eu
und deshalb per definition teuer für die
deutschen steuerzahler teuer wie die
bankenrettung die griechenland-rettung
die energiewende die grenzöffnung die
zerstörung der deutschen
automobilindustrie der
schlüsselindustrie und die gigantische
inflationierung unserer
gemeinschaftswährung zukunftsweisende
politik zieht an das auch sehr geehrte
damen und herren
nun also der drechselt und ihr anteil
daran denn den hatten sie im besten fall
aus fahrlässigkeit aber er war es
unterlassene hilfeleistung die
historisch guten beziehungen zum
vereinigten königreich werden auf diese
weise gefährdet was hatte david cameron
denn so fürchterliches verlangt keine
sozialhilfe sofort und für alle stärkere
nationale parlamente weniger
eu-bürokratie doch in brüssel hatte
damit auf granit gebissen
dabei wäre eine schlankere gemeinschaft
die sich auf ihre kernaufgabe besinnt
einen gemeinsamen markt zu schaffen und
zu erhalten eine große chance gewesen
aber nein das ging auf keinen fall da
setzten sie lieber den zusammenhalt der
eu mitgliedsstaaten oft spielten
und jetzt kriegen wir die rechnung 15
milliarden euro an britischen beiträgen
werden künftig im budget fehlen
zwar weiß jede familie dass man den
gürtel
enger schnallt wenn die einnahmen
schrumpfen aber nicht die eu muss sie
auch nicht solange der deutsche
steuerzahler der zahlmeister ist und
höher als das loch im etat sind die
kosten für die deutsche wirtschaft das
vereinigte königreich ist die
zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft der eu so
groß wie die 19 kleinsten zusammen
ökonomisch gesehen schrumpft die eu also
nicht auf 27 sondern auf neun staaten
zusammen die sorglosigkeit ja
gleichgültigkeit die brüssel und berlin
angesichts solcher größenordnung an den
tag legen grenzt an pathologische
realitätsverweigerung sehr geehrte damen
und herren und für deutschland ist das
vereinigte königreich der größte
handelspartner in der eu die
wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen sind so
eng wie mit keinem zweiten land
es liegt eindeutig im deutschen
interesse handel und investitionen
weiter ungehindert zu tätigen hier
stehen deutsche wohlstand deutsche
arbeitsplätze auf dem spiel sie aber
stellen sich in nibelungentreue hinter
frankreich das den briten sogar den
zugang zum gemeinsamen binnenmarkt
verweigern will ja sie erwägen ja sogar
noch mal die möglichkeit den briten
nicht den zugang zum europäischen
wirtschaftsraum zu verschaffen weil
paris das ablehnt das wäre ja auch alles
viel zu viel viel zu viel freihandel zu
viel frische luft auf den märken zu viel
wettbewerb und zu viel konkurrenz um die
besten wirtschaftsstandorte von
eigenständigkeit ist nichts zu sehen in
dem von ihnen unterzeichneten aachen
nach vertrag der welch ein dunkel als
krönung des eg vertrages gepriesen wird
aachen trägt eine französische
handschrift von vorn bis hinten dieses
europa für das das zentralistisch
organisierte frankreich mit einer
gescheiterten industrie und
wirtschaftspolitik als blaupause dient
kommt schneller
als man denkt und spätestens wenn im
europäischen rat das nächste mal
abgestimmt wird
da sehen wir es nämlich ganz genau denn
die teuerste konsequenz des black cities
dass deutschland keine sperrminorität
mehr in dem rad zustande bringt in der
aktuellen eu der 28 vertritt deutschland
16 prozent der bevölkerung
großbritannien 13
macht zusammen fast 30 mit einigen
kleineren ländern dänemark niederlande
österreich war die sperrminorität von 35
prozent immer gesichert
damit konnte man sich gegen den griff in
die gemeinschaftskasse
krisengeschüttelter club med staaten
sowie frankreichs wären und das ist nun
bald durch den austritt großbritanniens
geschichte und es wird deutlich ohne
reformen kann es in der europäischen
union doch gar nicht weitergehen wo ist
ihre strategie sie habe überhaupt gar
keine
fangen wir beim austritt artikel 50 an
heute vollkommen schwammig konkret wird
er nur beim hinweis darauf wie mit
abtrünnigen mit verrätern umzugehen sei
nach artikel 2 118 also wie bei jedem
x-beliebigen drittstaat kann man
eigentlich für einen partner mit dem man
40 jahre in guten wie in schlechten
zeiten zusammen gelebt hat nicht einen
anderen modus finden als für paraguay
oder papua-neuguinea sehr geehrte damen
und herren
das ist ja wohl der banken
und verwundert es dann noch wenn die
briten hinter jedem manöver aus brüssel
bösen welt vermuten was soll max it
unterhändler bahn je seinerzeit freundin
anvertraut haben mich zitieren
meine mission werden an erfolg sein wenn
die bedingungen für die briten so brutal
sind dass sie es vorziehen in der union
zu bleiben
wer solche freunde hat braucht keine
feinde mehr sehr geehrte damen und
herren von selbstkritik auf dem
kontinent ist nicht zu hören nicht in
brüssel ich in berlin schon gar nicht in
paris der box it hat die brüsseler
abgehobenheit deutlich gemacht er zeigt
auch wo europas waren gegner sitzen
unter anderem hier auf der
regierungsbank sehr geehrte damen und
herren
europa ist zu wichtig um es ihnen zu
überlassen wegsehen gilt nicht weglaufen
auch nicht die eu muss von innen
reformiert werden dazu gehört ein
vetorecht der nationalstaaten gegen
brüsseler vorgaben genauso wie eine
reform des austritts artikel 50 zur
erhaltung des binnenmarktes auch für
austretende länder und die sicherung der
eu-außengrenzen die wir seit jahren
fordern und zu europa gehören unsere
britischen freunde sehr geehrte damen
und herren vielen dank